I just got an awesome idea. My
government can import millions of people
who believe they're superior to everyone
outside their group and who demand
blasphemy laws to shield themselves and
their ideas from any sort of criticism.
Then my government can give these people
what they want, destroy my ability to
criticize ideas I find dangerous and
stupid, and turn me into a secondass
citizen in my own country. Pretty cool
idea, right? Yeah. Sad part is I didn't
even come up with it, so I can't really
take the credit. I got this idea from
the cowards and traitors who run the UK.
As we read in the Times, Labour's
Islamophobia definition gives grooming
gangs impunity.
definition will also shut down difficult
but necessary conversations about gender
equality and even Islamist extremism,
says Claire Coutino. If you thought the
grooming gangs acted with impunity
before, you ain't seen nothing yet.
Grooming gangs will be able to carry out
their crimes with impunity if a new
definition of Islamophobia is given the
go-ahad, the conservatives have warned.
Writing in the Times, Claire Catino, the
shadow equalities minister, said that
the definition risked intensifying the
culture of censorship by creating a
special status for one group over
others.
Yeah. Interestingly, there is a legal
system that gives a special status to
one group over others. It's called
Sharia, and British leaders absolutely
love it.
She claimed that Labor was only pressing
ahead with the new definition to stave
off the threat posed by pro Gaza
candidates at the next election. Steve
Reid, the new housing and community
secretary, has taken responsibility for
the policy after Angela Rener was forced
to quit over her tax affairs. In 2021,
Reed, who was then shadow local
government secretary, wrote to all Labor
Local Authority leaders urging them to
implement a definition of Islamophobia
drawn up by MPs.
So, we've got Muslims in the UK shouting
from the rooftops that they're going to
turn the UK into an Islamic state. But
instead of the British government
focusing on making sure that never
happens, they're focusing on
Islamophobia.
like good little demies.
Several labor authorities including
Telford and Recken, Ipsswitch, Kirkleys,
and Wakefield subsequently did so. Cino
said labor are doubling down by
introducing a state sanctioned
definition of Islamophobia, which will
intensify the culture of censorship that
allowed the grooming gangs to carry out
their crimes with impunity. An official
definition of Islamophobia specifically
designed to be adopted by our
institutions and public services will
shut down difficult but necessary
conversations about grooming gangs,
gender equality, and even Islamist
extremism. It would create a special
status for one group above others, which
risks further breeding resentment and
making our community cohesion problems
worse.
So, she's concerned not only that the
new definition of Islamophobia will
protect the grooming gangs, but also
that it will cause more resentment and
make community cohesion worse. In other
words, the government officially defines
Islamophobia and people are no longer
allowed to criticize Islam. This builds
resentment, so people will want to
criticize Islam even more and the
government will have to crack down even
harder on Islamophobes. This builds more
resentment and so on. But what's the
definition of Islamophobia they've been
working on. The spectator reports many
people have been warning for some time
about the perilous consequences of
introducing an official definition of
Islamophobia to this country
specifically in regard to its potential
to curtail free speech and reintroduce
de facto blasphemy laws. But it's taken
a leading KC, an adviser to the attorney
general, Lord Hermer, no less, to remind
us of a further danger, the likelihood
that it will deter police from
investigating Muslim suspects or
offenders for fear of accusations of
racism. As reported in the Daily
Telegraph today, Tom Cross KC has said
it was reasonable to suppose that such a
definition would in practice be relied
on in objecting to the use of powers by
the police and security services to
investigate persons who happen to be
Muslim for criminal offenses, including
of the most serious violent or sexual
nature. Cross added that a new state
endorsed definition of Islamophobia
could also be used to rewrite hate crime
and harassment laws.
If a Muslim is breaking the law, but he
says it's what his religion teaches,
police are going to be too scared to
stop him. So, Muslims will get a free
pass.
Hasn't the UK been down this road
already? Why are they trying to make it
worse? His misgivings are wellfounded.
The current definition of Islamophobia,
as yet to be ratified by a working group
commissioned in March by Angela Rener
and headed by former conservative
attorney general Dominic Grev KC is
fraught with future peril. This is
because it fatally conflates Islam, the
religion, with the ethnic minority of
most people in this country raised in
that faith. As it was defined by all
party parliamentary group in 2018,
Islamophobia is rooted in racism and is
a type of racism that targets
expressions of Muslimness or perceived
Muslimness.
That cynical definition sought to shield
both Islam and Muslims from criticism.
And there's little reason to believe
that the current working group will
deviate from it when it reaches its
conclusion.
Islamophobia
is rooted in racism and is a type of
racism that targets expressions of
Muslimness or perceived Muslimness.
So a Muslim calls Jews and Christians
the worst of creatures.
Are Jews and Christians allowed to
object?
No. Because calling Jews and Christians
the worst of creatures is an expression
of Muslimness. We read in surah 98:6 of
the Quran, "Verily those who disbelieve
in the religion of Islam, the Quran and
prophet Muhammad blah blah blah from
among the people of the scripture, Jews
and Christians and al- Mushrakun,
Mushrakun are people who associate
partners with Allah will abide in the
fire of hell. They are the worst of
creatures.
Jews, Christians, and other non-Muslims
are the worst of creatures. We're lower
than insects according to the Quran. But
surah 3 vers 110 says that Muslims are
the best of peoples ever raised up for
mankind.
Muslims are the best of peoples. Jews
and Christians are the worst of
creatures.
So, a Muslim can spend every waking
moment heaping abuse on Jews and
Christians. And not only are Jews and
Christians not allowed to insult the
Muslim back, they can't even object to
being called the worst of creatures
because objecting would be Islamophobic.
Suppose a popular British Muslim
announces on YouTube that once Muslims
get the political power, ex-Muslims will
be publicly executed. This isn't part of
our religion. There's a reason to it.
Yeah. There's a reason why there's a
capital punishment. Because people like
you, little weaklings who leave their
religion and cause uh corruption in the
land by spreading it, the capital
punishment in Islamic law would be
applied to you. We have no doubt and
we're proud of that. Will ex-Muslims
even be allowed to say, "No, please
don't kill us when you get the political
power."
Not at all. Because calling for the
public executions of ex-Muslims is an
expression of Muslimness. So condemning
it would be a form of racism, which
would make any ex-Muslims who object to
being killed racists and Islamophobes,
even if they're the same race as the
Islamists who want to kill them.
Keep in mind the people who are letting
this happen in the UK are the children
and grandchildren and great
grandchildren of the men and women who
once decided that they would rather die
than surrender to the Germans.
Now they're surrendering
not to an invading military but to
words.
Words.
You cried on that. You proud on that.
You just backfired on me. You proud on
that. You proud on that. You proud on
that. You just backfired on me. This is
a power of a religion. There's a reason
to it. Yeah. Yeah. Here.